thanks and thanks for inviting me to
speak so you know i'll confess my guilty
feelings up front which is you know the
talk is not uh going to be focused um on
causality or algorithmic aspects of
causality but i do think that causality
is important for fairness fairness is
important when you're thinking about
causality and i'll try to point out
those connections um
along the way
okay and also um if there are slides
that you like in my talk they're
probably from um at least one of my
collaborators there are slides you don't
like they're probably the ones that i
made and there are a few of them
okay so uh the talk today is going to be
about predictive algorithms which as we
know
are everywhere and are governing more
and more um aspects of our lives society
and this has many benefits you know
machine learning
can increase efficiency accuracy
you know can scale in ways that we
couldn't have imagined um a few years
ago but there are also concerns um and i
really like this example especially
speaking in california prop 25 for
eliminating cash bail um which you know
many people think that eliminating cash
bail is a
good goal
um but of course you have to replace it
with something the idea was to replace
it with a risk assessment algorithm
or that was a proposal it was rejected
by the voters and you know
let's talk about causality i don't know
why it was rejected but certainly there
were objections centered on fairness
okay so the aclu in particular said that
these types of risk assessment
algorithms or automated tools are
racially and socio-economically biased
and when we talk about predictive
algorithms there are sort of concerns
about fairness
everywhere
there are some prominent examples
slide i stole from michael
um
so you know what do we do we want the
advantages of
predictive algorithms automated decision
making machine learning but there are
these concerns fairness is one concern
we need to think about it we have
ethical and professional responsibility
to think about
fairness in particular about preventing
discrimination so we have minorities
protected groups in the population
and we want to make sure that our
algorithms are not discriminating
against them and that's the agenda when
i talk about fairness preventing
discrimination fairness can mean many
different things
okay so it's not a new question of
course you know there are millennia of
uh
discussions about fairness uh
in a variety of fields um i think that
kind of the impact of computer science
on algorithmic decision making and
prediction
uh has caused sort of an explosive
interest within computer science for
addressing these types of concerns
um you know i think in the beginning
maybe
we could say with a straight face that
maybe algorithms will make more
equitable decisions but by now we
understand that the algorithms sort of
inherit the bias from the data they're
trained on from the people who are
formulating the objectives
their biases have come up from the
algorithmic tools themselves as we will
discuss so we really need to do um
some serious thinking here
both when we talk about machine learning
also when we talk about causality
ideally what we would want um is this
holy grail to define fairness
maybe in a similar way to the way we
define
privacy and differential privacy or that
we define cryptographic objectives like
semantically secure encryption in the
world of cryptography so to have some
holy grail some beautiful definition
that will tell us what fairness is and
then we can build algorithms that are
fair
so this is i think a very
appealing objective it's ended up being
hard to pin down and i think the reason
it's hard to pin down is that fairness
means a lot of different things to
different people in different contexts
under different social norms
so really formulating one def it's clear
that we have to have if it's going to be
one definition it has to be sort of very
flexible to capture different things um
[Music]
and it's difficult to pin down what
discrimination might mean it can be very
subtle and i'll give some examples in
the talk so i won't get into that
right now um and you know coming at it
from a cryptographic perspective which
is what i do is we're familiar with
these kinds of situations when we talk
about cryptography or the world of
security we have lots of different
security concerns and so i think that
there's a very appealing research agenda
that we can sort of embark on which is
to identify and formalize the types of
concerns you know maybe it's not just
one concern maybe it's a hundred maybe
it's a thousand it's clear that there
are some prominent ones so we can
identify them we can formalize them and
we can mitigate we can build algorithmic
tools to mitigate uh discrimination
concerns and maybe along the way we'll
end up with kind of one definition that
unifies
all of the concerns that we have maybe
we won't i think it'll be a successful
research program either way
okay so causality when we talk about
fairness um
i think one hope that there is and i
like this hope
is that we can use caudal model causal
models to reason about fairness okay so
if we have a really good causal model
telling us what's going on in the data
what are the differences between
protected groups in the general
population between for example
men and women maybe we can use that in
order to
identify discrimination and to define
fairness and i think there was a very
compelling
approach of kusner at all
by using counter factuals so taking a
causal model and looking at for example
what the effects are
for men and then taking the counter
factual of how you know a person would
be treated if their gender was were
switched using that to identify
discrimination or define fairness it's a
very compelling approach um
but of course the difficulty with it
is that we know that all models are
wrong
and so for using the wrong model to
define fairness
well we might have a wrong definition of
fairness we might make things worse we
might fail to identify discrimination
when it's there
so
i think it's a very compelling approach
i'm very positive about it but there's
this core difficulty
you know what do we do when the model is
wrong and how do we use a wrong model to
define fairness or to
to make sure that we're identifying
discrimination and i think it's
analogous to another compelling approach
the approach of individual fairness of
work at all and there's some technical
analogy between these two approaches
this is work of mine um
with dwark alvento and sewer
yeah
so we're using the causal model for our
definition of fairness and the model is
wrong
[Music]
you know i should say you know the model
might be wrong but it also i mean that
doesn't mean that it's not useful and it
doesn't mean that the definition of
fairness based on the model is not
useful but we have to be very careful a
particular situation
yes
so
sorry
just think about so you started talking
about machine learning and prediction
and all these things so that relies on
inductive biases which is the model and
those could be wrong
so the whole name is is sunk if the
model is wrong so i don't understand
i i i understand the objection but i
don't understand how this objection is
specific to causal approaches to
firearms as opposed to literally
anything else
yeah
so
i think that causal you know causal
approaches have some benefits you know
so you know they allow us to do things
we can't do in other fields so there's
some hope for using them to reason about
fairness but we still have to face this
sort of poor difficulty that always
exists there's no it's not a magic
solution to our problem
but there was
this i'm going to put words in your
mouth guys there is an objection that
using
a
causal model to identify and define
the nature of variance or the conditions
by which you evaluate whether a model is
fair or not here's a problematic there
that doesn't exist
if you write down uh concrete definition
and require your predictive model to
achieve that
thanks michael
um
okay so that's in one direction
using causal models to help us
define fairness or help us identify
discrimination at the very least
definitions our definitions
um can be a little more tricky if we
actually can pinpoint discrimination we
can all agree that things are
discriminatory and that can be easier so
that's in one direction i think in the
other direction
the type of results and definitions and
algorithmic tools that i'll be talking
about today may be helpful
for addressing concerns about
discriminatory models so for example we
might have a model that causal model
that identifies effects very causal
effects very well in the general
population but misses what's going on in
a minority
and how do we think about that and i
think the kinds of tools that i'll talk
about today today may give um ideas or
approaches to handling those kinds of
concerns okay so that's kind of in a one
slide
uh
two takeaways for the relationship with
causality
causal models
okay but the focus today is going to be
on machine learning and prediction risk
risk prediction risk scores
um so let me start by setting up the
problem
so
we have individual instances and we want
to assign probabilities you know for
talking about whether what is the
probability that tomorrow it will rain
what's the probability that a given
individual's with features observed
features x will repay alone if we give
it to them
what is a probability given an image of
a tumor or certain features that it will
metastasize and cause cancer
what's the probability that um a
defendant um who's up for bail will
commit a violent crime if we release
them we'll recidivate okay so these are
the kinds of questions we want to answer
when we're talking about risk prediction
and the problem and it's a fundamental
problem in statistics in computer
science and machine learning is you know
what is the probability these are
non-repeatable events right we only get
to observe once whether this particular
individual repays the loan whether the
tumor metastasizes whether an individual
commits a crime or not so how can we
talk about probability when we only get
to observe the outcome once
um
we're not going to solve
this basic problem that's been debated
and you know are there probabilities is
everything deterministic these are deep
questions but we can formalize things
easily and i want to stick to the
following specific model
we have a distribution
okay we have over individuals throughout
the talk think of it as an um
distribution over people we get to see
observable features x
and outcomes y
boolean outcomes binary zero or one
throughout the talk
okay so did this individual with these
features
repay the loan
and once we can we think about once we
define this underlying distribution we
can talk about an individual's true
probability of having outcome one okay
of repaying the loan and that's what we
want to predict so given an individual x
i want to learn i want to predict what's
the probability that the outcome will be
one
again
we have this warning about probabilities
of non-repeatable events but this is the
model and now things i think formally
are clear
so our goal
is to use a training set of labeled
examples and then to be able to predict
the true probabilities or some good
approximation to them and we'll talk in
a minute about what a good approximation
can be so we want to design a learning
algorithm that gets a training set of
labeled examples and outputs a predictor
we're not going to be able to get our
hands in general you know we're trying
to deal with complicated questions like
what's the probability that an
individual will recidivate we're not
going to be able to get our hands on
perfect probabilities
hopeless
for these kinds of problems
at least you know given the features
that we have at hand so we want some
good approximation we want a predictor p
tilde that's a good estimate for every
individual for most individuals gives a
good estimate estimate of the true
probability of the outcome being one
okay so that's the goal um for risk
prediction
and when we talk about fairness there
are biases
um you know we have this sort of uh
sausage grinder that's taking the
data set the training data and producing
for us a predictor what's going on in
the data what's going on in the
algorithm and the objectives that are
set up what's going on in the predictor
that it's outputting
there are fairness concerns in every
stage of this pipeline
okay um and of course
if the data is biased then there's no
reason to think that the predictor won't
inherit the biases in the data okay so
for example if we're looking at
financial data and there's been
all sorts of discrimination against
minorities and you know due to that
they've received less loans or they've
received less favorable terms and
they've ended up repaying in smaller
rates
our algorithm will learn this
discrimination and will perpetuate it
there could also be further biases
induced by the algorithm okay so for
example machine learning algorithms
often you know use a regularization term
they try to simplify they try to produce
a simple predictor so if we have some
protected set that on average or more
likely to default the machine learning
optimization might end up giving on us
completely or to a large extent
including giving up on actual qualified
members of the minority so these are
there are many concerns about
discrimination i think these are two
good ones to have in mind um throughout
the talk today
okay so
how do we define fairness how do we uh
think about it there are lots of
different works i'll just i'll highlight
a few of them that are relevant for what
i want to say today
one approach that's what's i think most
predominantly used today in practice is
these notions that we call group
fairness so we think about a protected
group maybe a racial minority
maybe based on gender socioeconomic
status
so we take a protected group and we want
our predictor to behave similarly
whatever that means on the protected
group and on the general population
so
that's our goal or that's a group notion
of fairness and behaving similarly can
mean
very different things right we can talk
about statistical parity
so requiring that the predictor outputs
similar predictions on the protected
group in the general population
it just that might it might
make sense or it might not make sense
depending on the context in some
contexts it does make sense
in others it doesn't for example really
you know for some reason we really think
the protected group is more likely um
to
default for reasons that we are okay
with in terms of fairness
then we won't try to enforce statistical
parity but then we can still enforce
measures requiring that the predictor be
as accurate on the protected group as on
the general population we could ask for
similar false positive or negative rates
or we could require things like
calibration which i'll define shortly so
i won't get into it today but basically
saying that the predictions need to be
meaningful both on the protected group
and on the gen or similarly meaningful
um on the protected group in the general
population
so there are various things we could
require still i think at a high level
when you talk about group notions of
fairness there are several um
problematic aspects
first the fairness guarantees are
actually quite weak because they're only
in aggregate over the group
okay so in aggregate over the group
accuracy is similar between the
protected population and the general
population what does it mean for
qualified loan applicants for example
also these can be at odds with each
other so for example famously um
requiring similar false positive and
negative rates and calibration
simultaneously
basically is impossible unless you can
get perfect predictions
and i think a core difficulty is really
you know what is the protected group is
the protected group the entire minority
is the protected group the qualified
loan applicants
so when we just identify one or a few
disjoint protected groups we're really
missing out on
kind of the interesting guarantees that
we want to enforce
at a fine-grained
level um
there's a famous example um
that i think drives this uh point home
of dwark at all and their work on
individual fairness
and uh they talk about a steakhouse
that's trying to advertise and you know
the steakhouse is uh
racist so
it really doesn't want members of s to
show up
nonetheless you know maybe there's a
regulation in place or for optics
they need to they're required to enforce
statistical purity so they need to
advertise at similar rates to the
minority and to the general population
so what should the steakhouse owner do
well they just go ahead and they
advertise to the vegetarians in the
protected group and the meat eaters or
some fraction of the meat eaters in the
general population
so overall they achieve statistical
parity the rate of advertising to the
general population and to members of s
is similar but it's clear that this is a
complete abuse right they're not
advertising to anyone who's actually
going to show up in the protected group
so that's a failure of group notions of
fairness and now replace
vegetarians with or carnivores with
qualified loan applicants and you see
the problem
right
so really fairness depends on
identifying who the relevant subgroups
are for the task at hand and that can be
very difficult
so our perspective departing from group
fairness and this work that i want to
tell you about also a parallel work of
kieran zadal is we don't know who the
relevant subgroups are so let's just
protect every group that we can identify
given the data at hand and given some
reasonable computational limitations
so this works better for some notions of
fairness and for now for others and
particularly i want to tell you about
multi-calibration
which is guaranteeing calibration for
every group within a rich family within
a rich collection very rich collection
of sets okay so we're going to guarantee
calibration which i'll define in a
minute it's an accuracy requirement for
the members of s in aggregate and for
the vegetarians and for the carnivores
and for the carnivores that wear glasses
and for the carnivores that don't like
to wear glasses
um think about this family and this sort
of complexity theoretic perspective
think of it as a computational bound
okay so every group that can be
identified by a boolean circuit of a
certain size by a conjunction a decision
list etc
okay
i want to define calibration but
pausing for a question for a moment
everything is clear okay
so before defining calibration here's a
weaker requirement this is what we call
multi-accuracy for the predictor and now
the requirement will be that for every
subset for every subset in our
collection this can be an exponential
size collection
the expectation of the predictions
is similar to the expected outcomes for
that group okay so for example if we're
talking about a group of qualified loan
applicants the expected outcome is that
they will return the loan with very very
high probability and so the predictions
need to be very very high the
predictions need to assign them very
high probabilities of returning the loan
so that's a weaker requirement
calibration requires something
even stronger
okay so for example of the people in the
group for whom the predictor predicts a
0.9 probability of say returning the
loan really about 90 of them should get
outcome one and not only for the people
for whom the predictor predicts 0.9 but
actually for every prediction category
you know if we think about deciles for
the ones for whom they the predictor
predicts 0.2 20 should get outcome one
roughly zero point three thirty percent
to get outcome one etcetera
okay so this is a caliber this is the
requirement of calibration it'll come up
in the next two talks as well so you can
ask me a question if it's not clear now
um
and we require this not just for one
group one protected group but for every
group in an exponential potentially
exponential collection
so
i know this i um thinking further so you
chose this definition
of old families that can be recognized
in some sense right
it could be like i don't know families
that can be verified as membership
issues
or whatever
anything you can say about that
so talk i'll get to it later um
so i like the question you know as
always we're thinking out of the box
um
[Music]
we were really i think
you know perhaps uh some of us
understood it better than others i
didn't understand it as clearly at this
point
possibly omer and michael and ursula did
um
that really these families are talking
about
these are tests and i'll get to it when
we talk about indistinguishability but
these are sort of tests that are see
checking if something is wrong with the
predictions
and we're talking about
um
tests that can be computed by a
computing device of some sort
then i think the minute i think about a
computing device the most basic one for
me is the turing machine or a circuit
so tests you know
similarly now we think in photography
so i can alternatively think about it as
characterizing families that should be
protected or
yes
so nobody's going to catch me those are
the tests right they are applying right
right and i think you know as you're
suggesting maybe we could think about
much more powerful notions of tests like
interactive ones or games where there
are challenges and responses
and there are some extensions along
these lines in the later work and maybe
there's much more that can be done
so if the groups are individual people
like if the groups are individuals then
you're asking for perfect factors so is
the trick that you can't efficiently
identify individual people
no so you're right that the subsets i
just talked about the computational
limitation of identifying the subset but
in fact i'm also going to require that
they have some density in the
distribution and i'm brushing this under
the rug
okay so that's going to be our
requirement i think it's a strong
requirement especially if you think
about every set that can be identified
by a polynomial size circuit that's a
very strong
requirement and you might object and say
it's too strong maybe you're right but i
want to convince you that in fact it's
also a reasonable requirement or we can
get a lot out of it
so the flavor of results is that there
actually
exists for every family even an
exponential family there exists a
multi-calibrated predictor and it's not
much more the complexity of actually
computing the predictions is not much
more than just checking membership
in the families in the collection seat
so these multi-calibrated predictors
exist there's an algorithm for finding
them
okay there are questions about the
complexity the complexity is related to
the complexity of agnostic learning
um and i think one really useful fact
that i'll also touch on is uh in fact we
can impose this requirement census
acquire requirement is in line with
accuracy and no one has objected to that
so i'm just going to keep going and get
to it in the end
in fact impose this this requirement can
be obtained via post processing on a
given predictor and it won't degrade the
accuracy
um
[Music]
good so
i won't actually go into the algorithm
because i want to say other things but
just to tell you we do have an algorithm
and what it does is it gets as input the
collection of sets c
the tests as shuffy was saying
and a sample of label data
from the distribution
with grinds and grinds and grinds it
produces a predictor that is calibrated
on every one of these sets
simultaneously for every one of these
sets simultaneously the predictions are
calibrated
so the
predictor is not much more complex than
membership checking for groups in c
the running time of the algorithm can
depend on the size of the collection of
sets or does can depend unless you can
get a shortcut via some sort of agnostic
learning algorithm
um
so that's the catch it's a very simple
algorithm
um
so
let me go ahead because there are other
things i want to tell you about but i
just want to show that we can really see
the algorithms the algorithm is sort of
three lines of code it looks it starts
with a naive predictor say it assigns
0.5 to everyone and then it just
iteratively searches for a group where
the predictions aren't calibrated and
fixes the predictions on that group okay
until there are no such groups remaining
and then it stops and outputs the
predictor
um
the main question about the algorithm is
whether it will converge right like
maybe i fix one group and then another
group runs away and becomes uncalibrated
and i get stuck in some loop but there's
a potential analysis showing uh that you
won't get stuck in fact you can't
produce predictions that are
simultaneously calibrated for all the
groups and you can apply this as
post-processing so given whatever
predictor um you know maybe we have some
sophisticated neural net that someone is
trained some gigantic model
it's known that these models don't
necessarily produce calibrated
predictions so we can just apply this as
post-processing go ahead and iteratively
search for a group where the predictions
aren't calibrated fix it
do this for a few times the number of
iterations is bounded
and uh this won't hurt the accuracy or
at least not by much
of the predictor that we started out
with
like i guess i'm thinking of like the
neural network for example
if i have like a bunch of
things and then i post process stuff
given new thing like you assume i'm able
to change the prediction
yeah so i'm not changing i'm not it's
sort of black box i'm not changing the
weights of the net i'm sort of imposing
these little nudges on the different
groups as a post-processing on the
predictions that are produced
so
you know you might say nice theoretical
results um but maybe this is really
undoable in practice so we do have a
project with uh
nom we're here in the audience this is
bardait owl
um from colleep research where this was
applied to cardiac and osteoporotic risk
predictors
um so these are used
no i know i'm gonna tell you much more
about this uh than i can but these are
predictors that are you know best
practice uh used in medicine to predict
the probability of serious health
events occurring in the future and used
for preventative care
okay
so these predictors are known to be um
there's been literature showing that
they can be miscalibrated for minority
populations in this uh project what we
did is we identified a collection
of sets by looking at these five
different attributes um and all possible
combinations of them so for example
looking at the subset
a certain intersection of these fields
this uh created 360 different subgroups
and we looked at what was happening with
a best practice cardiac and osteoporotic
risk predictors that were being used in
terms of their calibration guarantees
and what would happen if the algorithm
by applying the algorithm or a variant
of the algorithm that i told you about
so this is for cardiac risk this is a
plot of calibration so
here on the x-axis we have the different
groups
uh the different cal the calibration of
the different groups and the number of
groups at each calibration level so one
is very good calibration that's sort of
here and then the further you go away to
the left or the right those are groups
where either the predictions are under
what they should be or over the risk is
overestimated or underestimated
this is the picture for the actual
predictors that are used with respect to
the groups that we identified and
applying um our algorithm as
you can see there's significant
miscalibration for many groups
and applying our algorithm as
post-processing we get much nicer
calibration guarantees
okay so almost all the groups are very
nicely the predictions are very nicely
calibrated
um noah will mention a little bit of
deployment of this so this was not
deployed but there was a different
deployment for covet risk prediction i
think novel mentioned it briefly in her
talk
the takeaway is that calibration was
significantly improved without hurting
discrimination it's also a fairly
lightweight post-processing if you want
to talk about interpretability maybe
there's an advantage to what we're doing
here in terms of really identifying
these demographic subgroups and
understanding what we're doing on them
sort of
informal
question
sure i was wondering since it's in line
with um prediction is there a way to
just um
like construct a better objective
function
same thing as your post-processing does
so
it's a good question of course you could
simply have the objective which looks at
the maximum calibration on any group and
use that as a loss function
one issue is a calibration in general is
not convex
so there are computational issues um
computational issues with that i know
homer and michael want to add anything
on that information consideration
yeah i think what you said is quite
accurate i don't think you can write a
single convex loss function
that there isn't necessarily one loss
function but uh i'll i'll
one convex
i'll i'll brag about three tips recent
work that shows that even though
multi-calibration doesn't make reference
to any loss function there are
consequences of obtaining
multi-calibration that imply
loss minimization for a broadcast
so i'll mention a little bit also the
connection connections between
calibration and lost immunization in the
time that i don't have them
um
okay so that's what i wanted to tell you
about multi-calibration um since that
work i think there's been
an explosion of different works that
sort of build on it change it
challenge it
i want to tell you about a few of my
a few ones
since i have the stage that i want to
talk about
so the first and this is going to your
question a little bit so instead of
talking about you know getting good
calibration for all the groups we could
talk about other losses right we could
talk about l2 loss l1 loss we talked
about whatever loss you can imagine and
beyond
and then we could define multi-group
requirements right we want for example
we were thinking about agnostic uh
learning type of guarantees we would
want that for every group simultaneously
the loss obtained is competitive with
some benchmark class maybe each group
has a different benchmark class
and we can obtain these and in fact the
way we can we can obtain them for very
general loss functions and the way we
obtain them or the way i know how to
obtain them goes through
multi-calibration i'll talk about that
in a minute
this is going back to shafi's question
so this has been strengthened in a
different direction showing
that calibration is somehow giving us
predictions that are indistinguishable
in a formal sense from the true
probabilities p star okay so the the
predictions really um cannot be refuted
by some class of tests that's related to
the collection of groups
and just given samples um from the data
um omir in his talk will talk about a
different direction
very excited i think is very exciting uh
showing robustness properties of these
calibrated predictors i don't know
robustness can mean different things but
basically showing that these predictors
can be used in lots of different
settings after lots of different
settings after they have been trained
and they're robust to the change in
settings in various ways
and i think my question or my hope um
for the audience here
is you know can we also
get these kinds of guarantees are they
interesting when we're looking at causal
models guaranteeing that the models
behave well
also on subgroups or with with respect
to large rich families of tests that we
can apply to the models
just to give you uh one idea and i'll
end there of the kinds of um
the strength of the multi-calibration
guarantee and this is a result with uh
galiona
basically saying that essentially for
any loss function
uh for which you want to obtain a
multi-group loss minimization guarantee
so any loss function
the audience here can think about a lot
but essentially any loss function you
can think of for which the guarantee
makes sense
for any collection of groups and for any
benchmark class
that you want to define you can obtain
predictions that are simultaneously
optimal or nearly optimal for all the
groups with respect to this benchmark
class and the way you do it is by
training a multi-calibrated predictor
okay so
given this loss function
and the collection of groups and the
benchmark class there exists a
collection of sets c prime it's not the
same until parikshit speaks it's not
going to be the same
as the original collection of groups but
it's a related
collection not much more complicated
such that if you train a predictor that
is calibrated for this collection of
groups it will also be competitive with
h for all of the groups in your original
set with respect to the loss function l
simultaneously and cheating a little bit
it's not the same predictor
that will be uh competitive but you can
tweak the multi-calibrated predictor to
get
one that is competitive
for all the groups in c
okay
so
just to sum up uh we have this concern
about discrimination in fairness it's
difficult to get a hand on
discrimination can be subtle think about
the steakhouse and the vegetarians it's
very dependent on the context okay so
advertising
a shampoo um differently to men versus
women is very different from advertising
a job differently to men versus women so
very context dependent
um
and we have this approach of multi-group
fairness calibration and beyond that can
deal with some of the concerns that we
have in a formal and systematic way
i do want to highlight that this was
dealing with concerns that are or this
was guaranteeing fairness that's
in line with accuracy with respect to
the data that we have
okay so if the data is flawed being
calibrated with respect to the data is
not going to save us i think that's a
very very interesting direction
or possibly the most important direction
uh
to keep hammering in on
and we have rich theory
uh implementations deployments
and i think the area is
really sort of up and running
i talked about
causal models and where i hope uh some
of this reasoning
[Music]
can find further applications or uses
um gal in her talk will
and i guess omer as well in a different
way both of the talks we'll talk about
how we actually go once we have these
predictions what can we use them for and
how
um i told you about this big concern
that if the data are biased we're really
going to be in trouble just learning
something that is you know fairly
reflecting the data won't save us if the
data themselves are biased
um and i won't talk about complex
resource allocation problems because i'm
out of time so i'll end here thank you
[Applause]
i love interesting yeah so
it's more remarkable
um
i understand all of this in the context
of
predictions
and i don't see the connection to
fairness at least the way i understand
this concept
it should be
that your
[Music]
rules are oblivious to
of specific desirable outcomes
now
when you're trying to improve
predictions of course you
very much want particular desirable
i'm not outcomes
i understand your question but i think i
i i just don't understand
this is a notion of therapist so
again going back uh it's not the notion
of fairness it's a notion
so for example a predictor that uh so go
back to the loan example the predictor
that's ignoring qualified candidates in
the minority that is finding the
qualified candidates in the general
population i think is being
discriminated
i i think okay so
my
way i think classically fairness
is that
your rules are oblivious to
um you know any desirable outcomes that
you may have but what's one setting in
which fairness is important is when
you're sort of setting rules for
individuals to compete
now the rules being oblivious to the
outcome i don't know what that i'm not
sure what that means but for example
what i'm trying to say is that
i think somehow
fairness can't be measured by
what comes out of it
uh i mean if you if you want to improve
your predictions on
uh you know whether or not people will
return their loans
then
uh
this is a reasonable
approach to to doing that but
i don't see why that implies fairness
so it might
it implies a certain type of appearance
which is the same yeah
no one is claiming that it will solve
all the various problems in the world in
particular you know you might be very
accurate
on the minority and still because the
data are biased they will get
predictions that are not reflective of
their true qualifications for receiving
the loan and they're still a problem
i think i do think that even if that's
the case if that's what we're concerned
about which i'm not sure it is but i'll
keep going anyway
um i'm not concerned about ranking that
i just
uh find
this definition of fairness to you
or defining
my particular goal
as
fairness i find that weird so i think
it's a certain type there's a certain
type of fairness addressing a certain
type of concern
i also think that if we want to think
about more classical concerns
other concerns like for example maybe
today so you keep trying you keep
talking about the results of how the
thing you have some system where i think
things are being allocated and you want
to make sure that the allocations are
somehow fair
that's a sense i'm getting so
no so
so my point is exactly the opposite that
judging
the fairness of an allocation by the
outcome of the allocation is not it's
not fairness
it's efficiency it's uh
uh you know accuracy it's whatever but
it's not fair
because fairness should
be something that ignores uh
the outcome of
it's it's it's a it's an innate
property of the rules rather than uh
what they produce
so i think that um
on some philosophical level i think
that's
an admirable approach but i think in
practice we have no way of knowing
because we don't know what the data are
because we don't know we set up some
rules and for example if you look at the
law of the law says very clearly in the
united states in some contexts
you are not allowed to look at you know
at a person's race and so long as you
are blind to the race attribute you are
here so it's about the process
it's not about the outcome
along the lines of whatever i understand
but how do i judge such a process
without knowing you know what the data
are basically not knowing what the
causal model behind the data is i can
never know what the causal model behind
the data is because i don't know what
the right model is and so what we are
focusing on is actually things that we
can measure
in this work there are other words that
talk about you know imposing some model
or imposing a metric and using that to
define fairness that's fine i don't
challenge john that i'm just saying
this doesn't have much to do with
therapies
it has to do with with other things you
may wish to
achieve but
i don't think i think it has to do with
uh something
which is fairness but we can take a
disagreement okay but maybe you missed a
slide or something
this library talks about
you know
for example so
if i understand correctly you're
calibrating against white pasta
all right your predictions are
calibrated on one set of data yeah
can you have any guarantees in turkey
fantastic so fantastic so that's a
question about generalization guarantees
and generalization error and
exactly
not just that
yeah so everything i showed was with
respect to
a hold-out set of data
the results are all measured with
respect to held up data from the same
distribution but you're asking a really
good question which is what do we do
about for example if i train a predictor
that is calibrated
on training data draw an iid from a
distribution is it guaranteed to also be
calibrated with respect to the
underlying distribution there's
fantastic work
so we address this for our particular
algorithm we
think carefully about the calibration
guarantee and for example there's no
problem with testing you know if you
hold out some data in your training
algorithm and you make sure you're
calibrated
with respect once you have your
predictor you make sure you're
calibrated with respect to the held out
data you'll be fine
in general thinking about generalization
with respect to calibration guarantees
is a good question and it's not
amazingly it's not well understood
there's a very nice work of
do you remember
recent work that's addressing this
problem and showing general sort of uh
uniform convergence balance of the type
we like um
based on things like i don't remember
whether it is a vc dimension in their
work for a different dimension based on
various different dimensions but i think
there's a lot it's not well understood
and there's a lot of work
yeah my question is about um
in what sense or if you could say a bit
more about like why you think that
calibration related concepts would
advance uh social justice or equity in
outcomes in a setting where
i mean you're kind of refining the true
predicted the true the true probability
of some you know repaying the loan or
whatever it might be
but that true probability
in our actual world is very bad it's not
a thing that we want to
respect if if that true probability is
influenced by this history of
oppression marginalization and
mechanisms that were historically and
presently unfair and so i don't want to
preserve the true probability of
repaying the loan because it's sort of
tainted by this
by this badness
so
yeah it's a fantastic question i mean
it's a depressing question but it's a
fantastic question and i think this is
really the big challenge
that i was trying to point out is what
do we do when the data are not what we
want to perpetuate and sort of
accurately reflect that's exactly the
question
and i want to say that even then
if what we are doing with the data is
first training a predictor it's very
reasonable to take the data the you know
the data that has all of these horrible
biases
inherited from the real world
train a predictor and try to understand
what's going on and fix it
okay so that's a very natural approach
um
you know you could do other things i
think this is a natural approach and if
that's the approach you're taking your
predictor had better accurately reflect
what's going on for different groups so
you can fix it
so you would better start with a
predictor that is multi-calibrated or is
certainly not ignoring what's going on
with the groups in the flawed you know
data that we want to fix
okay so i think this is a natural
even when we're doing that i agree with
you that that's the important question
that's an important question there are
contexts where i think this is you know
we're multi-calibrated for example a
medical context
depending on what what country you live
in medical data can be more or less
biased and then you know maybe it does
make sense to talk about
multi-calibration but in many settings i
agree that it doesn't that we want to
fix what's going on in the data and i
still think this is this can be a good
starting point
[Music]
yeah i think that unless you're just
going to the data and doing freeform
exploration which you know maybe made
sense if the first thing you're doing is
sort of trying to
train something that is telling you in
this data what are the probabilities
trying to get your hands on the
probability of the data what you are
starting with and better accurately
reflect what's going on in different
subgroups otherwise you know we can't
make problems
is the post-processing assuming sort of
like a back setting where you have a
bunch of
risks i guess i'm thinking like if i'm a
doctor or something i see like one
patient and i want to get them
to support them
for them already do i need to wait until
i collect like a whole
group of patients and then run this
calibration and then return yeah so the
results i talked about were in a batch
setting but there are lots of works
both works
older works and newer works that talk
about online settings where patients
come in the individuals come in one by
one and you want your predictions to
have been calibrated in hindsight or
multi-calibrated in hindsight and their
algorithms produces so it can be
achieved
i don't
if someone has a reference from one of
the recent works of kieran's and roth
there are several verbs
if there's like an individual that's
part of
many more groups than other individuals
does that mean that
uh like asking for working celebration
would
await the the impact of that
individual's data on your predictor
i don't
um i knew the answer offhand
we'd have to think about we'd have to
find some notion of what impact an
individual has on on the
we could think about it by defining some
notion and maybe like the shackley value
or something like that uh the effect
that an individual has on the
predictions and think about it that's an
interesting question
let's take other questions off